c'est le clash que l'on n'attendait pas
Valérie Pécresse versus Beyoncé moi je
pense que c'est Beyoncé qui va gagner
alors
vous l'avez croisé dans le train et
alors elle est comment en vrai
ben
je suis rassurée
il va se produire au Stade de France le
26 mai prochain et en moins d'une heure
tous les billets ont été vendus alors
beaucoup aurai aimé avoir une deuxième
date dans la capitale d'ailleurs mais
c'est impossible parce que le producteur
de la star qui pointe du doigt les
travaux sur les voies du RER B voilà
Beyoncé rattrapé par le RER pour les
fans la responsable est toute trouvée
mais pour la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France varie Pécresse qui est
mise en cause et au pas question de
porter le chapeau
il parait que c'est de ma faute je vais
rectifier les choses et le dire
clairement je n'y suis rigoureusement
pour rien on va recevoir
mon cousin
mon cousin Abdellah
j'ai le dollar mais faut pas charrier
rien de personnel mais Valérie Pécresse
rebaptisé Queen vie depuis à tout de
même un conseil pour la star la
prochaine fois il faudra prendre un
producteur qui vérifiera que le stade
est disponible à la bonne date pour pas
se défausser sur les autres ça n'est pas
très courageux
c'est tourner événement les médias sont
en boucle dessus avec parfois des
pépites comme ce bon plan pour payer sa
place destruyers
NBA LeBron James balles record de points
moments historique on passe le sportif
ce qui m'intéresse c'est derrière
regardez ce moment historique comment
l'ont vécu les appareils
ou presque un téléphone il y en a même
qui regarde ce moment d'histoire à
travers l'écran du téléphone incroyable
selon une étude 53% d'entre eux ont déjà
publié des photos de leurs enfants sur
les réseaux sociaux parmi eux la moitié
publie des clichés de leur enfant dès
leur naissance et même parfois dès leur
conception quand il s'agit de la famille
Pélissard 98 paniers historiques de
Michael Jordan je vous montre ce que à
quoi ça ressemblait donc il a six
secondes en finale et là
voilà là il y avait de l'émotion à
l'ancienne et là il y en a pas un alors
il y a un gars
qui est là avec son appareil photo en 4
fois
il avait le smartphone mais en fait si
oui le comparatif est assez saisissant
la photo d'un enfant n'a rien à faire
sur Instagram ou Twitter sa place elle
est dans un album de famille ou dans le
disque dur d'un évêque mais
qu'on a
Rachida qui vous voulez embrasser
Christelle avant de partir alors je vais
embrasser mon mari Guy mon fils winner
winner c'est génial comme prénom c'est
winners
Louis Boyard aujourd'hui on peut le dire
est un héros grâce à l'arcom qui vient
de rendre son verdict dans l'affaire
Louis Boyard contre TPMP il sanctionne
C8 à une amende de 3,5 millions d'euros
sachez que c'est comme ça c'est voilà on
sait pas pourquoi 3,5 millions c'est ça
ça tombe comme ça c'est voilà
donc ces 3,5 millions d'euros merci on
fera pas de commentaires l'arcom a
estimé que ses propos ont porté atteinte
au droit de l'invité au respect de son
honneur et de sa réputation elle a
également considéré que cette séquence
traduisait une méconnaissance par
l'éditeur de son obligation de maîtrise
de son antenne 3 millions et demi
d'euros c'est un record absolu
sur le produit
par contre les monteurs si jamais vous
mettez ça il y a des chaînes accès à des
fréquences gratuites en échange de
certaines obligations qu'elles doivent
respecter ces obligations il suffit de
les lire elles sont dans la loi elles
sont très claires c'est le rôle de
l'archange en Suisse au moment de faire
le bilan de ses obligations de vérifier
qu'elles ont bien été respectées pour
pouvoir ensuite
évaluer si la reconduction de cette
fréquence et justifier ou pas
parce que les boulettes et on dit pas
mal tu es resté
tu vas avoir des soucis parce que là
c'est franchement c'est un moment c'est
pas toi qui va le dire en fait c'est
comme si on fait comme si on fait une
recette de cuisine à côté tu pourras
trouver que c'est pas bon mais c'est
parce que tu sais pas en fait C8 et
c'est news pourrait perdre leur
fréquence il y a des obligations à
respecter il y a déjà eu une vingtaine
d'interventions de l'arcome depuis 2019
pour C8 et ses news je rappelle juste le
4 qui existent alors Rima doule Malak on
va communiquer que je fais je vais le
dire dans un instant mais juste en fait
déjà c'est pour 2025 à la reproduction
donc vous inquiétez pas parce que j'ai
vu plein de gens qui sont inquiétés ou
est-ce que c'est 8 va disparaître pas du
tout c'est vite sera là vous inquiétez
pas c'est pour 2025 il y a pas une faute
à marseillais
c'est Marseille vs
c'est pas possible alors je suis
contrarié mais en même temps j'ai envie
de rigoler parce que je me dis cette
faute elle est ridicule mais dans
l'autre côté mais les gars vous m'avez
vu l'écrire aussi personne n'a rien dit
quoi donc remarqué ça la dernière minute
c'est bien beau mais sur le coup vous
n'êtes pas mieux que moi et Dieu sait où
sera la ministre en 2025 nous on sera
encore là en tout cas elle on sait pas
vous savez les ministres de façon
généralement vite non mais c'est vrai
voilà on sait pas la ministre on a on a
plus de chance d'être là que la ministre
voilà
non mais c'est vrai voilà on sera
peut-être chroniqueuse en 2025
pourquoi pas oh non mais c'est vrai
pourquoi pas elle ils ont fait une faute
ils ont fait une photo
ils ont fait une faute à marseillais
c'est le nom de leur famille marseillais
la honte ah mais là ça ça va leur suivre
toute leur vie
[Musique]
notre ami Claude Nougaro
il a chanté plein de chansons c'est un
Toulousain ce monsieur c'est un grand
chanteur plein de petits détails sur la
musique moi-même un chanteur qui
s'appelle Claude naguro franchement il y
a plein de choses Claude naguar
son nom c'est Claude nous garer